today on the matt welsh show donald
trump is on a righteous crusade against
critical race theory now uh i think now
is is a time also to expand that mission
into the schools where critical race
theory is the most dangerous so we'll
talk about that
also five headlines including the the
media's misinformation campaign
about what overturning roe v wade would
actually mean
and our daily cancellation i'm afraid
that i have to cancel
amy coney barrett and i'll explain why a
lot of a lot of dirt has been dug up
about this woman
and we're gonna have to talk about that
today all of that on the way but first
you know you know seeing the check
engine light turn on uh can give you
anxiety i
i just recently had that happen we were
going on a long car ride and
right before we went on the car ride the
light comes on and it's this moment
where you go oh man you know now what
but now that i have car shield i don't
worry about that stuff anymore car
shield offers a wide variety
of protection plans that can give you
thousands
uh save you thousands for a covered
repair which means that the check engine
light is a lot less scary when it comes
on because you know you're covered
you have the freedom to choose your
favorite mechanic or dealership to do
the work and car shield
gets the rest taken care of even if your
car breaks down while you're traveling
uh the choice of a repair shop is still
up to you on top of that
there's no long-term contract there's no
commitment payments are flexible car
shield plans are customizable to your
exact needs
um you know i personally used i used to
dread car repairs i used to dread
uh the light coming on but with car
shield i have peace of mind
and it's hard to put a price on that get
coverage today and see why car shield
cars
go further call 800-665-2157 and mention
codewalsh or visit carshield.com and use
codewalls
to save 10 that's car shield.com
codewalsh
a deductible may apply also one other
note make sure you um
after the show as i've been telling you
if you're watching on youtube and
you need to go subscribe to my personal
youtube channel that's youtube.com
matt walsh all of my shows will soon be
available exclusively on my personal
channel
you can still listen of course on itunes
or many other places but
if you want to watch on youtube you've
got to go to my personal channel
youtube.com matt walsh all right
president trump in recent weeks has been
on a crusade against
critical race theory i believe this is
possibly the most important thing he's
done with his presidency
even if he hadn't taken any active steps
against it to simply shine light
on it to make people aware of it and two
as the leftist would say
proble problematize it i guess is the
phrase that is an enormous public
service
but trump has gone further than that
he's um and here's the latest he tweeted
this last night he said
a few weeks ago i banned efforts to
indoctrinate government employees with
divisive and harmful sex and race-based
ideologies
today i've expanded that ban to people
and companies that do business with our
country the united states military
government
contractors and grantees americans
should be taught to take pride in our
great country and if you don't
there's nothing in it for you um so
that's a very good thing critical race
theory is a scourge it is an
ideological cancer it has infected our
societal bloodstream
and the effects have been devastating
the racial strife in our country today
riots much of the violence
this can all be traced at least in part
back to critical race theory
now i think before we go any any any
beyond that though i think we probably
first have to answer a basic question
which is
what is critical race theory and for
that so that you know i'm not giving you
a biased or cherry pick
definition i will go to a liberal source
i'll go to the boston globe article it
was just written which is meant to be a
defense of critical race theory
hence first henceforth referred to as
crt by the way just for short and also
dismantling dismantlingracism.org which
is an online resource that's supposed to
help you
well dismantle racism though as we'll
see
probably constructing racism or
spreading racism would be a better name
for that website
uh first here's the boston globe article
it says scholars say the president's
remarks about crt
prove he fundamentally misunderstands
critical race theory and its aims
i am a thousand percent sure that trump
does not know what critical race theory
is i have never been more sure of
anything in my life
said kiara bridges professor at the
university of california berkeley law
school
and author of the textbook critical race
theory a primer
she goes on and he certainly doesn't
understand the debates within and about
critical race theory
scholarship by critical race theory
emerged in the 1970s and 80s in response
to what legal scholars perceived to be
the failures of
traditional efforts approaches to
thinking about race and civil rights
which tended to conceptualize racism
very narrowly according to bridges
as a problem of individual bad actors
the movement's architects including the
late derrick bell the first tenured
black professor at harvard law school
and kimberly crenshaw a professor at the
ucla school of law and columbia law
school who first coined the term
critical race theory
um says racism is not extraordinary
she continued race and racism are
basically baked into everything we do in
our society
it's embedded in our institutions it's
embedded in our minds and our hearts
then it goes on despite the progress and
promises of the civil rights movement
critical race theorists argue that
racism infects all of our societal
institutions
from public education to the criminal
justice system
what appears to be progress in the law
is actually concealing a new modality of
structural societal ra
systemic racism that according to rajesh
sampath
an associate professor of philosophy of
justice rights and social change
at brandeis university namely our laws
and
constitutions don't protect everyone
equally he said
okay so that's the boston globe
racism is embedded in everything we do
america is racist down to its very core
american well white americans are racist
in their hearts and their minds
everything is racist racism is
everywhere
and even even when it looks like racism
is being addressed
by laws and policies really those laws
like constitutional provisions
guaranteeing equal rights for example
they are just creating quote new
modalities for racism
so then we go over to
dismantlingracism.org which says
here's what it says racism is ordinary
the normal way that society does
business the common everyday experience
of most people of color in this country
racism serves the interests of both
white people in power
the elites materially and working class
white people physically and therefore
neither group has much incentive to
fight it later on it says white
supremacy is ever present in our
institutional and cultural assumptions
that assign values morality goodness and
humanity to the white group
while casting people of communities of
colors and communities of color
as worthless immoral
bad and inhuman and undeserving and then
it defines racism as
racism equals race prejudice and social
and institutional power
racism equals a white supremacy system
all right so what does all this mean it
means that
everything is racist again racism is
everywhere
america is a white supremacist country
but also importantly
racism is a uniquely white phenomenon
only white people can be racist racism
equals a white supremacy system
now there are a few problems here of
course
first of all you know this this
obviously is nonsensical
it doesn't even take into account the
existence of the whole rest of the world
even if i agreed that in this country
black people can't be racist because
whites
uh against whites because whites have
all the power which i most emphatically
do not agree with that but even if i did
what about say
china or india there's a lot of racism
in india
racism between and towards non-white
people racism directed from one
non-white group
to another non-white group what about um
for example a person in india who hates
black africans
and that is not an unheard of phenomenon
i can tell you to put it mildly
by this definition of racism that's not
racist
this definition of racism has no way to
account for that
so you see here this weird dynamic where
critical race theorists while hating
white people also in a strange way
put white people on a pedestal or at
least at the center stage of the world
play
um when talking about things like racism
or slavery for that matter
they pretend that nobody else exists and
that everything revolves around white
people
and so somehow white people are
responsible for things that have existed
in human civilization
literally since its inception feminists
do a very similar thing with men by the
way hating men
um but yet also centering their whole
lives and world views around men
so this is a common theme on the left
but okay um
going along with the crt camp and
pretending for a moment
that india doesn't exist and china
doesn't exist two countries that are
rife with racism
but pretending they don't exist what
about here
is it true that in this country only
whites can be racist because whites have
all the institutional power
no that's a false conclusion built on a
false premise
and it's so faulty and so stupid that
even if the false premise was true
the conclusion still would be false
because it doesn't follow from it it's
not true that whites have all the
institutional power
that is observationally false you can
look around for yourself and see
that not all institutions are run by
white people nor are all institutions
dedicated to the advancement of white
people there are a lot more white people
in positions of power than black yes in
terms of raw numbers
but that's because there are a lot more
white people period
black people are 13 of the population a
minority of the population is also going
to be a minority of most
institutions at all levels that's just a
mathematical inevitability
but even so whites don't have all the
institutional power
we did have a black president after all
and though the left scoffs at that
response to the america's racist charge
scoffing is not an argument it is an
absence of an argument
you can laugh and roll your eyes all you
want the fact is that you cannot say
black people don't have institutional
power
when the most powerful man in the
country for the eight of the last 12
years was a black man
that claim makes no sense it is
incoherent
what about laws are laws constructed to
advance white people
no in fact the opposite
there are no laws no laws period at all
that explicitly favor white people no
laws
in this country at all there are laws
that explicitly disfavor white people
affirmative action
and related policies okay you cannot
provide an example
of an affirmative action type thing that
explicitly favors whites
because it doesn't exist it does exist
on the reverse
so all of that is wrong but the fact
that that facts don't support critical
race theory and
actually contradict it every step of the
way is irrelevant of course
crt is a religious system it is a dogma
when you read a supposedly scholarly
explanation of crt
what you're really reading is a
catechism the idea that racism lies at
the root of all things invisible and
undetected
and that racism itself is some sort of
strange and mysterious way
in some sort of strange mysterious way
is a white invention or or a tool
wielded by western white civilization
even though even though racism existed
in humanity before western white
civilization even existed itself
and certainly before it had power like
it does today these ideas cannot be
factually proven or supported
and that's by design they are statements
of faith not fact
and those who teach crt or rather
proselytize it are not looking to
convince you on an intellectual level
they're looking for your spiritual and
emotional ascent
and if they can't have that then your
cowed submission will have to
do and that is why trump you know i
think should expand his war against this
poisonous religious ideology beyond
federal
contractors and into schools where it
really starts
and where it's the most dangerous it
should be banned from public schools
it should be banned on the basis that it
infringes on the first amendment
if teachers cannot get up in front of
the class and insist that their students
accept
jesus christ as their lord and savior
that they shouldn't be able to get up
and insist that
you know their students accept critical
race theory dogmas either
these are both religious doctrines the
fact that in my view
one is true and one is not is irrelevant
i don't want
public schools demanding fealty to
religious dogmas even christian dogmas
so i think it should be banned from
public schools ban it from public
universities
impose financial penalties on any public
education
institution that promotes it personally
i think teachers who use their power and
influence to brainwash children into
this horrid
superstition deserve to go to jail but
fines and defunding would suffice for
now i guess
if people want to you know go out on
their own and explore critical race
theory
and pledge their devotion to its tenants
they're free to do that
but our public institutions should not
be in the business of promoting it
which by the way the fact that our
public institutions
do promote critical race theory is
ironically
proof in itself that critical race
theory is false
but i don't expect its proponents to
connect those dots because one thing
we've learned about critical race theory
is that it certainly doesn't involve any
critical
thinking let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
listen people get hacked on the internet
all the time it happens it happens quite
a lot as i'm sure you heard and
one of the worst things about that
happening to you is that you're gonna
you're gonna feel dumb if it does happen
because you didn't take very basic
precautions that you could have taken
identity theft has become a big time
crime with criminal gangs operating
units dedicated just to this
certain behavior can make you more
vulnerable to identity theft um
not checking your credit card or your
bank statements okay like a lot of
people don't look at it
and and that's going to leave you
vulnerable using the same username and
password on every account
um never checking your credit report
over sharing personal information
i think we've all been guilty of at
least some of this it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet and you could miss
certain identity threats
if you're just monitoring your credit uh
or if you're not doing anything at all
then you're certainly going to miss a
lot
good thing there's lifelock lifelike
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale in the dark web many other
things as well
um and if they detect your information
is uh is at risk
then they're going to send you an alert
um and
and that's that's going to be one of the
one of the most important things of
course again
there are basic things we can do to take
precautions but you need to get lifelock
it makes it really easy for you no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out
if your information is for sale on the
dark web get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com walsh pick the plan that's
right for you
25 off uh your first year with promo
code walsh
that's a free scan at lifelock.com walsh
and 25
off with promo code walsh
all right let's begin with this because
uh we're going to see and hear a lot
of this in the coming weeks here is
alison camerota
on cnn talking about
what what she thinks will happen if roe
v wade is overturned listen
i think one of the interesting
discussions about abortion is that the
country is generally
divided i mean almost split right in
half about how they
view it however in the latest gallup
polls
20 of the country oh i should say only
20
of the country wants to outlaw it okay
so you can feel differently
about the different nuances of it but
only 20 wants to outlaw it
and that's ultimately you know obviously
what would happen if roe versus wade
were done away
with and so it's just interesting i mean
obviously we're segue into a political
stance here but if the country does
you know would support the direction
that this is going in
well this is why uh when uh
republican presidents nominate justices
to the court
they try to pretend that it's some
mystery what their views are about roe
versus wade because they know the
country is against them on this issue
yeah so alisa camarata is either stupid
or lying
uh or she could be both i don't mean to
limit her okay i don't want to limit the
possibilities here
but no overturning roe would not mean
that abortion is outlawed
okay in fact if roe is overturned the
next day
abortion is still going to be legal
everywhere
the laws are not directly affected at
all by overturning roe v wade
no what it would do is it would make it
possible
for individual states to pass laws that
would then restrict or possibly ban the
practice
it enables them to do it it doesn't mean
that it happens
and some will do that some some states
will pass laws like that some won't
does camerata think that california and
new york are going to ban abortion
because roe is gone
no if anything they're going to pass
laws that
just encourage it even more in
retribution
um only the very strongly and
overwhelmingly conservative states will
ban the practice i think what's going to
happen what's what's going to you know
you're going to have some you have a few
states that ban it outright a few states
that like i said go even further in the
other direction
i think what's going to happen in the
majority of states is that you're going
to find more
restrictions and that's in line with
what most americans
feel and what their what their opinion
is of the practice
now of course when it comes to something
like this it doesn't matter how most
americans feel about it
this this is this is a basic human right
that's being infringed upon you've got
60 million dead babies since roe v wade
um i don't care if every single american
in the country
loves it uh it it it's still it still
should be banned and if we could ban it
across the country i would be in favor
of doing that
but that's just not the reality that's
not what we're talking about here
um you would need something like a
constitutional amendment
protecting the personhood rights of
unborn children which i would favor
but we're not anywhere close to that
happening roe v wade simply allows
states to make choices
and that's if if americans can be made
to understand this
then i think the majority
would be in favor of overturning roe v
wade
but keep this in mind i don't know what
the polls say but you're going to see a
lot of polls
how do polls how do americans feel about
overturning roe v wade
whenever you read those polls keep in
mind that a large number of the people
taking the poll
don't actually know what overturning roe
v wade means
and a lot of them are going to think
that it means
exactly what allison camerata says
because that's what the media is telling
them okay number two uh take a look at
this this happened at a car dealership
in the bronx
so that's a gang fight that broke out at
the car dealership
but uh in if you're if you're listening
to this on the audio podcast it's
at a car dealership bullets start flying
and at the bottom of the screen there's
a a dad sitting
on a couch i guess in the waiting room
with with looks like three or four kids
um and as soon as the bullets are flying
he
he he lays on top of the kids shielding
them from the bullets actually he took a
bullet in the thigh
i believe he's gonna be okay his kids
are okay uh if he hadn't been lying on
top of them who knows where that bullet
will
would have gone but you see i think with
this footage
you see sort of the heights and depths
of masculinity
um the contrast really it's real
masculinity verse fake masculinity
and you and you see both of those things
uh illustrated in that video and
you know certainly in our culture we
could use we could use a lot more of
of the kind of masculinity that you saw
which is the real which is real
authentic masculinity the kind that you
saw happening there playing out at the
bottom of the screen that's what we
could use a lot more of
in this country number three the media
today is very disturbed very disturbed
very troubled very very troubled uh
so deeply troubled because trump made a
joke at his rally last night about a
reporter being thrown to the side by
cops let's listen to that
they grabbed them they were grabbing
them left and right
sometimes they grab they grab one guy
i'm a reporter i'm a reporter
get out of here they threw him aside
like he was a little bag of popcorn
but no but i mean honestly when you
watch the crap that we've all had to
take so long
when you see that it's actually you
don't want to do that but when you see
it it's
actually a beautiful sight it's a
beautiful sight
and they had the same thing on some
other streets and the whole thing was
gone and i haven't heard of any real
problem in minneapolis since that
happened i mean they were just burning
down the city and that
idiot was standing there this is a
friendly protest and it's right
and behind him was like 10 blocks of
fire was now i have to agree that is
that is extremely
troubling i think um i am also disturbed
by that
i mean trump says they threw him aside
like a bag of popcorn
that is no way to treat a bag of popcorn
the fact that trump thinks the fact that
trump thinks of popcorn as a thing that
you throw to the side
what kind of analogy is that throw to
the side like a bag of pop who throws
their bag of popcorn to the side
so if i give you a bag of popcorn you're
just gonna toss it to the side that's
not
i mean is that what he does at a movie
theater they hand him his large popcorn
just she just chucks it over like that
um i think this statement from trump
reveals a really problematic attitude
about popcorn and that is a national
conversation that i think
we need to have number four new york
post has this story i think this has
already been announced but uh here it is
again it says actor jim caviezel
who played jesus in 2004 as the passion
of the christ said
writer director mel gibson has written a
forthcoming sequel
mel gibson just sent me the third
picture of the third draft it's coming
he told breitbart it's called the
passion of the christ resurrection it's
going to be the biggest film in world
history
while kaveh 51 may talk a big game the
first film was no slouch made on the
made on the relatively modest budget of
30 million
it took uh it took in 622 million
worldwide
um let's see and then it says so
what the new film the actor said would
depict his uh
jesus's biblical resurrection and the
events that followed now
um yes first of all biggest film in the
world
that's i think that that may
that could very well be the case this
movie is going to make a gazillion
dollars
passion of christ made 622 million um
and keep in mind that that's not even
adjusted for inflation but also keep in
mind that was a
a movie that was rated r uh you know not
not not really a kid friendly not a
movie you're gonna bring like your
eight-year-old to right
um because it's it's pretty gruesome now
it is actually what happened to christ
so
i think it's a great film uh but not for
very young kids
if we're talk if we're doing passion of
christ resurrection then probably it's
gonna be a little bit more
family-friendly it's not gonna be quite
as gruesome i would think
this is a mel gibson film so you never
know um and so if there's
if it's not rated r so you're taking a a
b
a bible movie not rated r made by a
a mainstream and great film director and
mel gibson i think that's a you know
that's a billion dollar movie at least
for sure
um my only question though is how much
so
what i've read in the past is that this
movie is going to be
it's going to tell the story of jesus
his resurrection
up to the ascension and that's going to
be the whole movie now
if we were going into the book of acts
and we we were and mel gibson is showing
us what's going on with
peter and paul that would be obviously a
great film and i would love to watch
that movie
i'm just wondering if there's enough
biblical material between resurrection
and ascension to make a movie
because the gospels cover that in like
four sentences
so this if that's if that's the time
frame we're covering
then mel gibson's gonna have to
freelance quite a bit
and add in a lot um so that could get a
little
dicey but uh i think it's i think it's
great
and this is you know it just it kind of
shows you
how much hollywood hates christians
that they're not making bible movies
like five bible movies a year
because these movies make a ton of money
there's a huge audience for them
even when they're not good mel gibson
makes a great one
some of the bible movies we get aren't
even good they still make a ton of money
there's a huge hungry audience for this
material and yet for the most part
unless mel gibson comes along mainstream
hollywood is not making these movies
uh with a few exceptions okay five
finally rioting in portland continued
last night
as always um but then the antifa rioters
took a break
from the rioting for a little musical
interlude
actually they started moshing at least
that's what this is supposedly is
a video of but you tell me let's let's
let's take a look
[Applause]
i do not know this cultural tradition
at all
[Music]
okay that is not a mosh pit first of all
that's that's more like a tickle fight
a tickle pit if you will tickle pits by
the way would be a great name for maybe
an indie band
but that video really just underscores
the important point that i always like
to highlight which is that antifa
are domestic terrorists yes but they're
also enormous dorks
and let's never lose sight of that never
forget that
these are the saddest flabbiest
scrawniest
most awkward weakest most pathetic
little punks you'll ever encounter
in your life but then when a bunch of
them have crowbars
and and bricks and stuff yes they're
dangerous
of course you could give a you could
give a whole bunch of 12-year-old
cheerleaders crowbars and bricks and
they would be dangerous too
so you could give that to toddlers and
they'd be dangerous also that that's not
really telling you anything about about
the toughness of the individual people
individually
they're they're exactly what you saw
right there
uh but a whole big group of them yeah um
they are terrorists and and they are
dangerous
okay we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but before
we do
you know uh i think a lot of uh right
now it's it's a challenging time
for business owners when they're looking
to hire um
and this is something that that that all
business owners are thinking about now
you're looking to hire where do you go
how do you go through that uh monica
starks could relate she needed to hire
for a pivotal role at her construction
company gs group but was having a tough
time finding the right person especially
with so many candidates out there
so she switched to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you
it finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply so
they're going to go out and find these
candidates
it's not like you're just you're posting
a job ad into the
ether and it's sitting there no zipper
crew is going to go they're going to
find them
which is why you should try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
walsh that's how monica found lamont
jenkins
uh she said that zip recruiter sent
lamont's profile to her around five
minutes after she posted her job because
he was a great match for the role
and that is that's something that you
hear from people who use recruiter all
the time
is that it doesn't it doesn't take very
long it's like minutes for a lot of
job roles and already you have qualified
not just any applicants you have
qualified
applicants who are um willing and able
to take the job so you can see for
yourself how zip recruiter makes hiring
faster and easier
try it now for free that's right free at
ziprecruiter.comwalsh
that's ziprecruiter.com walsh walsh
ziprecruiter.com
walsh let's get to our daily
cancellation today for our daily
cancellation we're going to cancel
amy coney barrett we are canceling her
based on the horrible dirt that
democrats have been able to dig up about
her
i just can't in good conscience support
her after after i've seen this
now it's of course widely anticipated
that trump will select barrett to take
the supreme court seat that republicans
callously intend to fill even though
democrats have specifically said that
they would prefer to do it
um it's also widely anticipated that the
dems will dig up many dark secrets about
the judge
just in time for the confirmation
hearings it's hard to know what those
secrets will be mainly because chuck
schumer
hasn't invented them yet perhaps it will
be discovered that she's an assassin for
the mob or that she
poaches the tusks of endangered
elephants or that she's a
serial killer and neo-nazi and reptilian
shapeshifter who frequently double parks
and never tips the pizza
delivery guy after brett kavanaugh was
uh was exposed as the ringleader of a
roving band of teenage gang rapists
really anything is possible so the full
truth about barrett will come out soon
enough
in the meantime democrats and their oppo
research team at the washington post
have
already unearthed i think a significant
amount of dirt
and this is but a foretaste of what is
to come
it's already enough to send shivers down
the spine as the media has only just
begun to demonstrate amy coney barrett
is a dangerous woman so let's go through
there are four things here
here are four scandalous facts that have
already been uncovered
about amy coney barrett number one she's
a catholic
not just catholic but an extreme
controversial worst of all conservative
catholic
she's the one to whom senator dianne
feinstein a few years ago famously
charged
the dogma lives loudly within you let's
watch that again
i think in in your case
professor
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you and
that's of concern when you come to big
issues that large numbers of people have
fought for
for years in this country now on top of
that a disturbing expose in the
washington post showed that
barrett considers her legal career and
indeed her whole life to be quote
but a means to an end and that the end
is quote
building the kingdom of god now one
might protest that this is a standard
view for any devoutly religious person
well yes and that is precisely the
problem devout religious conviction
is deeply troubling unless as with joe
biden it's the sort of devout religious
conviction
that wouldn't be out of place at a
planned parenthood fundraiser
number two she is part of a charismatic
christian group that literally
inspired the handmaid's tale as newsweek
brought to light this week
barrett belongs to a group called people
of praise now this is an organization
so backwards so patriarchal that it
actually served as the basis
for margaret atwood's dystopian novel
about a future where women
are subjugated and enslaved by men this
is stunning
as a side note it's also not at all true
um newsweek later ran a correction
admitting that in fact
there was absolutely no connection
between people of praise and the
handmaid's tale
uh so there was it was entirely false
but that's irrelevant
the fact is that barrett's group could
have inspired the book
so even if it didn't it still did
in a certain way when you think about it
number three
she believes in due process for men
yeah proving that the connection with
the handmaid's tale is very real
even if it isn't at all another reporter
from the washington post reveals that
barrett wrote quote an influential
decision making it easier for students
accused of sexual assault
to challenge universities handling of
their cases
this flies directly in the face of the
sacred legal principle that a woman
never lies
and should always be believed unless she
accuses a democrat in which case she's
probably a russian spy
number four she is anti-abortion
now as yet another washington post
article described it her anti-abortion
position is perhaps the most
problematic aspect of an already
alarming record
but i prefer the eloquent directness of
wandi ortiz's refinery 29 article
uh which says that amy coney barrett
quote hates your uterus
now you might argue that barrett's
opposition to abortion stems from her
scientifically provable
provable position that unborn humans are
human and therefore dismembering them in
the womb is
no more justifiable than dismembering
them anywhere else but i think ortiz's
article gets closer to the heart of the
matter clearly
barrett hates your internal organs and
wants to enslave women
because she's been brainwashed by a
radical religious cult that didn't
inspire the handmaid's tale
but totally could have these are just
some
of the ominous red flags and we haven't
even talked about the fact that barrett
has
like a lot of kids which is pretty weird
let's be honest
one can only imagine what other
skeletons may be
stowed away in the closet indeed let's
hope that democrats
are imagining some really scary ones as
we speak
but that's all icing on the cake
we already know enough to know that this
is a dangerous radical
and she should be disqualified from
consideration
and certainly we know enough to cancel
her
uh but other than all that i'm sure
she's a fine person
now we're gonna i guess that's it for
the show but i do want to mention one
other thing before we wrap up
um as we're talking about you know
different ways that you can watch the
show and experience it
as part of our daily wire audience there
are a number of ways to take in the
podcast you can listen on apple podcast
you can spotify another podcast app of
course we were talking about youtube go
to youtube.com
matt walsh go to my private uh my
personal page
you can go to facebook dailywire.com
bottom line we're making our content
available
in a lot of different places daily wire
members can now also enjoy our shows on
apple tv and roku so members can enjoy
all the visual elements of this podcast
and other shows on our big screen either
live or on demand find the daily wire on
apple tv or roku
and download today you have to be an
insider member to watch live so head on
over to dailywire.com
walsh use code watch at checkout to get
5
15 off your membership purchase this
deal is not going to last for long
so you want to go there again it's
dailywire.com walsh
get 15 off with code watch and download
the daily wire app
uh on apple tv and roku today all right
that's it for us today have a great day
everybody godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there